Traductor: Agostina Sicardi
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Tenia 18 años cuando una compañera
me convenció para empezar pintura
con la profesora Marta Zuchetti.
Yo dibujaba desde muy chico
pero solo por hobby
Recuerdo que lo primero que me hizo pintar
fue lo que se denomina naturaleza muerta
Para los que no conocen
era un jarrón con un par de frutas
y otros elementos arriba de una mesa.
Era una prueba para evaluar mi capacidad.
Después de varios trabajos prácticos
me dijo que podía comenzar
con mi primera pintura.
También me aclaro que a todos sus alumnos
la primera obra solo se la dejaba hacer
con lápices de pastel
pero que a mi me permitiría
la técnica que quisiera.
Yo en ese momento era fanático
de los Redonditos de Ricota
Y me pareció una buena idea,
como mi primera pintura.
No tenía manejo del oleo
ni de trabajar con pinceles
pero igual me compré un lienzo
de 80cm por 1m y comencé.
Terminarlo me llevó
aproximadamente unos 6 meses.
A pocos días de finalizarlo,
se realizó una muestra en Rosario
donde expuse junto a mis compañeros.
Antes de viajar, Marta me comentó
que en toda muestra
siempre hay una obra que llama
la atención de los espectadores.
Recuerdo ver como la gente se concentraba
alrededor de mi pintura.
En ese momento, un grupo de personas
me llamó para hacerme preguntas
¿Cuántos años hace que pintas?
¿Qué número de obra es?
Cuando yo les digo que recién comenzaba
y que se trataba de mi primera pintura,
pude ver caras de asombro
seguido de halagos.
Esa experiencia me dio empuje
para seguir pintando.
Al año siguiente comencé la carrera
de Diseño Gráfico en Rosario.
Mientras cursaba los fines de semana
trabajaba como diseñador en "El Alargue",
un periódico deportivo de la ciudad.
En ese momento les propuse a los dueños
dibujar a los jugadores en caricatura.
Les encantó la idea y es así fue todas
las semanas se publicaban los dibujos
en la contratapa del diario.
Después de varios meses recibí un llamado
de Fernando Vergara, un profe de fútbol,
que en ese momento trabajaba
en Los Molinos
y me comentó que tenía de hobby
escribir cuentos de fútbol
si me interesaba ilustrar esos cuentos.
Me aclaró acá no hay un mango,
es solo por pasión.
Ya llevamos 14 años como amigos.
Publicamos dos libros
de cuentos de fútbol
y este año estamos por publicar
el tercero que se llamará "La Silvia".
Además en el 2018, inauguramos
nuestra página web
llamada "Por el chori y la coca".
Hasta hace tres años atrás,
estaba acostumbrado a dibujar o pintar
en el escritorio de casa.
La verdad, una forma bastante solitaria
de la cual ya no estaba disfrutando tanto.
Pero un día al ver un artista
pintando un mural en la ciudad,
me despertó la curiosidad
y las ganas de hacer lo mismo.
Así fue que un domingo soleado realicé
el primer mural en el patio de casa.
Para el segundo tuve que esperar
un miércoles feriado,
elegí una pared de un galpón que
daba a una placita a la vuelta de casa.
La elección del lugar fue por dos motivos:
el primero porque me quedaba muy cerca
y el segundo porque era un placita
por la que no pasaba mucha gente
y si me quedaba mal, no se vería.
A medida que iba pintando,
comenzó lo interesante.
Chicos que pasaban en bici,
se acercaron a mirar.
Vecinos que por el momento teníamos una
relación de hola y chau,
me empezaron a contar
historias y vivencias.
Muchos compartían la misma pasión
que la mía
pero que la vida los había llevado
a trabajar de otra cosa.
Esa fue mi primera experiencia con
las personas y me pareció maravilloso.
No todos conocían a Nelson Mandela,
pero si compartían su idea.
Con este mural conseguí dos récords:
el primero terminarlo en solo tres días
y el segundo este: lo vandalizaron
un día después de finalizarlo.
La noticia se hizo viral rápidamente
y con esto descubrí que las personas
que me felicitaban y compartían mi obra
en las redes sociales
ahora me daban palabras de aliento
y fuerza para que siguiera pintando.
Esto me recordó una frase de Facundo
Cabral que dice "el bien es mayoría
pero no se nota porque es silencioso, que
una bomba hace mas ruido que una caricia
pero por cada bomba que destruye
hay millones de caricias
que construyen la vida".
Si Mandela pudo soportar 27 años preso,
luego salir, ser presidente
y acabar con la desigualdad racial,
¡Cómo yo iba a bajar los brazos!
La verdad es que nunca
me lo tomé como algo personal.
Sabía que pintar en la calle podía tener
estas consecuencias.
Nunca imaginé que podía pasar tan rápido.
Hacía un tiempo, venía con la idea de
pintar a la Madre Teresa de Calcuta.
Ya tenía el boceto pero me faltaba el
lugar, cuando ocurre una casualidad.
Era un día de semana, afuera un calor
que no se soportaba.
Yo estaba esperando que un amigo
abriera su negocio.
Como faltaba un ratito aproveche
para irme a tomar un helado.
En eso entran las maestras y los chicos
de una escuela católica de Pujato.
Mi novia ,que formaba parte de las
maestras, me presentó a la directora
y en los 15 minutos que hablamos
le muestro el boceto.
Y a la semana siguiente ya estaba
pintando en el colegio.
De estar en el patio de mi casa
a pintar en otra localidad,
me generaba nuevas sensaciones.
Estaba inquieto, contento, ansioso
por no saber qué persona iba a conocer,
cómo me iban a recibir y si realmente
podía cubrir la expectativa de ellos.
Una vez más, me encontré con gente
maravillosa.
Tanto los grandes como los chicos
me acompañaron en todo momento
y hasta me invitaron al almuerzo
de fin de año del colegio
Pero de todas las personas
que pasaban por el lugar,
me sorprendió un caso en particular.
Un hombre frenó con su auto
y desde arriba muy emocionado
me dio las gracias por la obra.
Me dijo solo falta que hable.
Cuando se retiró me contaron que había
sido uno de los fundadores del colegio.
Ese fue el momento exacto
en que comprendí por qué pinto.
Comprendí que como artista es mi deber
conectar con las personas
tratar de emocionar, sorprender
o inspirar.
Hoy el lugar tiene luces, bancos, flores,
el busto del fundador del colegio
y el mural de la Madre Teresa
bendecido por el obispo.
Poder ver cómo a una simple acción
se le suman otras acciones
para mejorar un lugar, es increíble.
Hoy estamos acostumbrados a escuchar
palabras como crisis,
corrupción, violencia.
Los medios de comunicación nos muestran
todos los días la parte mala del mundo.
Por eso intento con cada mural
dejar mensajes positivos
que nos unan un poco más como sociedad.
Generalmente pinto personas
que me inspiran
y tal vez puedan inspirar o cambiar
algo en el otro.
Estoy convencido que para cambiar el mundo
no se requiere de súper talentos,
sino de pequeñas acciones diarias,
como decir buen día, buenas tardes
o ayudar al que tenemos al lado.
Además, tener un talento
requiere una gran responsabilidad.
Y si ese talento no es usado para el bien
de la sociedad, no tiene sentido.
Y recuerden que la vida, como los murales,
son efímeros,
pero lo que hagamos con en el corazón
vivirá para siempre.
¡Muchas gracias!
(Aplausos)